if you run a global organization
based in london
and you don't have a single person on
your staff who sounds like me you [__]
up
because how can you possibly have the
best people but look we've created a
system where you can get paid a million
pound a year over there or you could get
you want to work in media you have to
work for seven eight years on 30 grand a
year you have to do unpaid internships
only rich people can afford these jobs
so we end up with media full of rich
idiots government full of rich idiots
universities full of rich idiots and
anyone who's half smart is making a
million quid over there to shut the [__]
up
and you're surprised when the economy is
a disaster
this is what we've done we've created a
system where we selectively pick all of
the best people who should be helping to
fix this economy to protect the people
of this country to build a good future
for this country and for the world and
all they're allowed to do is sit over
there and bet on disaster making money
for themselves you know i'm out here
listen